хотіли би звернути вашу увагу на ту
інформацію яка йде останніми днями від
наших високопосадовців щодо
е економічного стану наприклад заява е
прем'єр-міністра України з якої він
звернувся до е партнерів про проведення
термінової зустрічі
ее з тим щоби визначитися як Україна має
пережити січень лютий чи до березня нам
треба чекати буде катастрофічно не
вистачати нам підтримки наших партнерів
Бо вся підтримка йде саме на виплати
бюджетникам на забезпечення соціальних
виплат і Якщо її не буде то у нас
насправді буде ситуація або з частковим
зменшенням цих виплат або взагалі треба
зрозуміти як ми переживемо декілька
місяців насправді наприклад пенсіонери
пенсії яким виплачується частково за
рахунок єдиного соціального внеску який
з сплачують роботодавці і який звісно
частково забезпечить виплату пенсій це
одна історія А що робити з вчителями з
лікарями я чую просто е питання весь час
зі сторони вчителів вони взагалі
вважають себе тими про кого забули під
час війни ми маємо зараз переглядати всю
видаткову частину державного бюджету ми
маємо на цьому зараз сконцентрувати всі
зусилля ми зараз маємо мати і уже в
Верховній Раді Він має бути винесений
цей План Б що буде відбуватися з
видатками по більшості розпорядників де
ми знайдемо той ресурс який потрібен для
того щоб забезпечити людей всім
необхідним мінімальним чим зараз
забезпечує держава коли я
прочитала нещодавній документ який був з
погоджений на Кабінету Міністрів
національну стратегі доходів ну Вибачте
там левова
частина в в намірах що мають вони
зробити Що має зробити влада це ті
рекомендації
які постійно надаємо ми європейська
Солідарність Я особисто і ті мої зусилля
які я витрачала при прийнятті бюджетів
на 2023 рік на 2024 рік коли аналізувала
кожну статтю видатків зараз мають нати
Мінфін терміново і не говорити ні про
які зупинення виплат Я особисто подавала
поправок на більше чим 90 млрд гривень
про зменшення видаткової частини це саме
ті гроші які треба було спрямовувати в
2023 році на збройні сили на
військовослужбовців я би бажала всім
зосередитися саме на цих питаннях і
говорити людям правду Все ж таки що ми
очікуємо в найближчі місяці і подавати
швидше розроблені документи щоби ми
могли реагувати уже в Верховній Раді і
швидко приймати зміни Я хотіла би ще раз
наголосити ми нічого не боїмося ми
спільно вистоїмо перед любим ворогом Але
нам треба спільні зусилля для розуміння
один одного і для дій заради цієї
витримки